We wondered yesterday and the day before,
why is Donald Trump trying to stop
the vote in states where he's losing?
If you stop counting, you're still losing, then
you lose. And Donald Trump's aides, we now have
learned how to explain to Donald Trump, you know,
if you stop counting ballots where you're losing,
you will lose the Trump campaign filing lawsuits
in multiple states to stop the vote counts. Trump
says there's electoral fraud even though there's
been no evidence of it. He tweeted Thursday, Stop
the count. And New York magazine's Olivia Nuzzi
said she learned of a phone call in which Trump
said he assumed everybody knows when he says stop
the count, he doesn't really mean stop the count.
He means just stop counting fake ballots. So
aides were able to persuade Trump to instead
of saying stop the count switch to stop
the fraud, which Donald Trump eventually
did after his stop the count tweets, aides were
reportedly scrambling to get Trump under control,
saying Biden will win if we succeed at stopping
the count. And then this is just amazing.
When Olivia Nuzzi asked, does the White
House understand the math of what's going on,
Olivia Nuzzi says that they do not.
According to The Washington Post, Trump
senior advisers intervened and explained to him,
be precise about which vote counts should stop
and why tweeting stopped. The count looks bad and
indeed they were right. It looks very, very bad.
Stopping the count yesterday, by the way, would
have guaranteed a victory for Biden in Arizona,
would have guaranteed a victory for
Biden in Nevada that 17 electoral votes.
Trump doesn't even know what he's asking
for. And after the explanation, Donald Trump
switched to tweeting, stop the fraud instead
of stop the count. Imagine being in your 70s
and being just the rich, privileged dude and
just you don't understand how counting works.
You don't understand the implications of if
you're losing and you don't count anymore,
you don't win. Imagine inheriting 400 million,
ending up a billion in debt, calling yourself a
successful businessman and ending up as president
of the United States. And this is what I'm going
to say next. We're going to spend a lot of time
on in the next few weeks. He almost became a two
term president. If he had been slightly better
on the virus, despite everything that's happened,
he would have sailed into a second term easily.
We will discuss them. Follow us on Instagram
at David Pakman show. Follow me
on Instagram at David Pakman.